hello I'm Eric Davis we are at South by
Southwest Film Festival with Star Wars
the last Jedi director Rian Johnson
producer ROM Bergman star Mark Hamill
hello
so Star Wars last Jedi is available at
home today right now
I noticed you know it's stuffed with
some really fun deleted scenes and so I
guess I want to start I'm curious at
what point do you decide like we're just
gonna put a bunch of deleted scenes on
here versus we're gonna do an extended
cut or a director's cut like was that
ladder ever no I would never do an
extended a director's cut I just kind of
I feel like the everything that was
taken out even the stuff I really loved
was taken out for a reason and I'm happy
people get to see it but the movie
became what it became for a reason and I
feel like the the cut we put out there
is the best cut of the movie
I love the caretaker party scene I
remember right I was talking to you a
few months ago and you told me that
Return of the Jedi was a bit of an
influence on this film and I watched
that scene and I immediately thought
completely yeah yeah that was one of our
big creature scenes and I was like and
just having fun with those creatures and
kind of it was a great day on set
because they choreographed this old
dance
this old dance routine and they had
these goofy instruments that they were
playing and yeah I was that's something
that I'm really it was a bummer man
hitting that delete button and taking
that whole section out but it's also one
of the lessons that yeah Luke gives to
to Rey yeah it's a great day between you
two what's with the lessons well if you
see the scene she learns one and it's
sort of a mean thing for Luke to do and
he laughs about him so I like that part
about it because it shows you that even
a suicidal old grump as a this sense of
humor still glimmers down below yeah it
was one of the few moments in that film
that we we saw Luke kind of yeah yeah
exactly and I mean and he does teach her
a lesson but you know she learns the
hard way and he she says why didn't you
tell me and I just ran slow it just it
just reminded me
you know my uncle he used to do he he
had and my wife's got a mean streak she
showed me a video of a dog that had they
put little mittens on and he didn't like
amazing my reaction is that is so mean
and she's like no it's not good
documentary the director in the Jedi I
loved and I knew when you did this film
I was like he's gonna make a really
awesome behind the scenes kind of nerdy
documentary out of this and so there's a
couple of moments that I just loved I
loved your reuniting with Frank Oz and
and Yoda and and what was that like for
you well see it's unexpectedly emotional
you know I walked in going oh boy I get
to work with Frank and it's just you
know all your the sense memory of going
back all those years especially when you
thought you'd never I mean I've seen
Frank over the years I haven't seen Yoda
over the years and the fact that they
would go to the old school puppetry
again rather than put a piece of tape on
and have Frank doing the voice and it
was it was special because they didn't
have to do it that way and they did that
did you have to ask permission to like
to bring Yoda back or you're like I'm
just gonna write Yoda in here and
they'll figure it out like how did that
no I mean really early it may it just
made all the sense in the world that if
we were gonna have Luke on the island
and once especially it became clear that
this was going to be as arc it made so
much sense to have you to come back as a
force ghost and was gonna talk to yeah
that's the thing and so and also because
he was to you what you kind of were
supposed to be for right and so once we
did it in my head besides just wanted to
work with Frank besides just wanting to
do the puppet it also made sense to do
the public cuz that's the version of
Yoda the Luke knew from Empire it's the
last version you saw so but yeah Neal
Scanlan who ran our creature department
it's detailed in in the doc you can see
the process they went through the mold
found the original mold they don't
mention this but they actually found the
woman who painted your this original
eyes all they found her
she was still around and they had her
repaint the eyes for you though I mean
they really took it to the enth degree
to make that public work and I I also
loved the moment Luke and Leia's moment
towards the end of the movie I think you
see just how emotional it was for Kari
to has she's crying when you you hit cut
was was it also very emotional for you
what was that well well because you know
obviously I wasn't on when I read seven
I thought we were gonna get to work with
Arison again and that was hard and then
you know so I relished the fact that we
had a moment at all and you know it was
like I say the the the movie deals and
all those issues of closure and it is
stated right out forget the past kill it
if you have to and he's doing a pretty
good job yeah first hon then Luke I said
to Carrie I said if this is a pattern
you're next you know she just laughed it
off and said well at least I won't be
glowing green but we we understood at
least for our characters it was goodbye
forever and that's always tough it was
like you know that last scene
moment in a way go on girl you know did
you ever think over the years like have
a vision of like I think this is how
Luke should die and how different or
similar was it to how Ryan wrote I know
I really didn't my son nathan is he did
you know you'll say Oh dad you know
they've cloned your hand there's an evil
you know he tells me I have a beautiful
redheaded wife you know which they
kindly provided ten years after I
finished so it's I mean it's
overwhelming the amount of the amount of
ancillary material the video games the
comic books the role-playing games etc
etc but I you know I had to let that all
go it's an interesting thing because you
know you see in the documentary I've
been passionate about these things but
once it's in Ryan's hands and John
Williams is doing is music I mean they
don't need the actors anymore except for
ADR you'd have to let it go and I have
this strange kind of since you can't go
back you can't change it that's why it's
so hard for me too
see these films because I don't like
looking at myself you know why did I do
it this way you know it could be trivial
you know I don't like the way my hair is
or whatever it is yeah it does it
belongs to the public now it doesn't
belong to me yeah I think a lot of the
movie is about letting go let go of
everything you think this is and embrace
what it could become you know about the
things we keep from the past though and
that's the thing I feel like the the
quote have let the past die gets gets
kind of latched onto because it's a big
it's kind of like the big sexy quote of
the movie but the truth is if you really
watch the movie that's not where the
movie ends up landing you know
completely it's an aspect of it but I
think realizing that there is power and
the old stuff also and that hwisun we
need that and that's how essentially
what Luke fulfills at the end of the
movie is stepping into that role you
know what to mention the big sex scene
where they never let me touch a finger
you know that the fan response to this
movie has has been loud everybody's got
different opinions about it I think for
the bold decisions at brilliant
decisions I think that you made in this
movie has has that response kind of
impacted the way you're approaching the
next Star Wars movies in any way no no
really I mean it feel like every Star
Wars thing that ever gets made has a big
loud response because Star Wars fans are
passionate and that's what makes them
awesome yeah and so but no and and and
you know it's I don't think it's
possible when you're if you're really
telling a story you care about and
having it come from your heart it's kind
of it's just not possible to be
intellectually processing like what
everyone else wants and and nor would it
be a good thing a healthy thing I don't
think that's a good way to tell the
stories this is the only movie series
where people go on Twitter and say I
swear to God if in the solo movie X Y or
Z happens I'm totally out air so they're
like anticipating things they're not
going to like you know our worst fans
that's what you do because because you
love this stuff so much when you see the
documentary she looks like a
nine-year-old playing with action
figures but it's all
a big set but he has the same enthusiasm
and youthful exuberance that is just so
charming you know and he's going he's
gonna go beyond the Skywalker's yeah now
and I mean not with this dysfunction
what do you want to see though like what
would you want to see from from the
future stalwart listen I I really
enjoyed the prequels and rogue one
because there was a hundred percent less
hammer there's no pressure you can just
sit back and relax and take the ride and
you know that's what I'm looking forward
to the on solo yeah but but you're still
practicing your force ghost for episode
no well I don't know I mean it's just I
can't confirm or deny but you know again
I like to have fun on Twitter so you
know I tweeted that thing that because
they said something about well you you
wrote left hand would another metal and
just cranked it and I said well I mean
my theory is that he just forced
projected to somewhere else with the
metal and and no clothes so the nudist
planet well it's a crazy theory it's not
meant to be real and lots of people you
have to remember people don't get irony
a lot on on Twitter mostly why they
don't get it so but you know if anything
you know after years of being a
trickster and a joker people should know
don't take anything I say seriously yes
well hopefully we see back in some form
for the next one congratulations on the
last jet even Star Wars movie and and
good luck moving on thanks Billy thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
you